my buddy Peter King back here on the
show how are you Peter hey Rick you know
what is absolutely amazing I just
listened to your rundown and obviously
there's so much going on but that game
last night was one of the most
incredible football games for the last
minute of play that I've ever seen
because there are so many things that
are left to discuss and try to figure
out I I was I was blown away by it it's
not the least of which was Marshawn
Lynch after five years
jogging onto the field with seconds to
go to her what we thought was going to
be a one-yard plunge and the biggest one
of the biggest runs of his life after
coming off the couch I mean there are
just so many weird things about it and
yet it's almost like we forgotten about
that and nobody cares about that because
you know everybody wants to know who's
the next coach of Team X Y & Z well I
mean interestingly enough that that
possible run by Lynch from the one-yard
line never happened because there was a
delay of game penalty after which a
throw into the end zone led to a non
pass interference call and then no buzz
in from New York City and as I started
to show Peter well I mean as I started
the show it's exist the the fact that
there was no even stop to review this is
exactly the situation in which the
Saints didn't get the call last year
leading to the review process to be
changed for this very moment and not
even a buzz in just to say yeah we
didn't see enough in the quick spot cuz
we don't want to mess with the flow of
the game how I'm just wondering again
what our River ons job status do you
think how things stand with that going
into we're all talking about coaching
statuses what what do you think his role
moving forward with the NFL is going to
be Peter I
he could he could very well be the fall
guy for the debacle that has been the
the pass interference review rules
change
I mean rich somehow someway in late
March in Phoenix Arizona we all sat
there and we all heard why exactly the
rule was being changed to allow you know
to allow the review of both pass
interference calls on the field and then
what wasn't called on the field and then
once the season started we learned that
even though that rule was in the books
they were going to use it basically and
and look you know we've talked about
that forever what bothers me is that
that was the exact situation last night
that was that was that that was supposed
to be fixed by it and for Al River on to
come out and say nothing to see here
in his a pool retort statement after the
game I thought was is somewhere between
stunning and and irresponsible but but
again that's that's like one of five
things that happen in the last half
minute of the game that just absolutely
shocked me one of which was rich one of
the reasons why okay they get the delay
of game call and Marshawn Lynch comes
jogging onto the field they get to the
delay of game call but you have to ask
yourself if it is if you're in the
one-yard line
and you have no timeouts left and
there's 22 seconds to go yeah the
question is are you going to give it to
Marshawn Lynch for you know for a plunge
to try to make it and if he doesn't make
it what do you do spike the ball and
then you're on fourth down with I don't
know with ten seconds to go
I it's if it was I think it was
exceedingly poorly planned by Pete
Carroll Brian Schottenheimer and the
Seattle Seahawks and then again it just
it just Rican
figured the seedings that that last
minute of play were everything it's the
difference rich between playing two home
games to get to the Super Bowl versus
playing three road games to get to the
Super Bowl that is what that single
thirty second sequence meant to the San
Francisco 49ers it's just just one of
the biggest cuts biggest a series of
plays in recent NFL is yeah and again
what it also meant to is that Green Bay
would have to get on a plane to Santa
Clara to again if all the seedings play
out to get to the Super Bowl and we all
know what happened when Green Bay last
visited there it was a total washout on
NBC San Francisco dominated Green Bay to
you one of the real mystery teams
although it is in one way Peter that
it's a mystery to me why we're not
talking about them right and in the same
way that again the reason is that you
got Matt Lafleur not getting credit for
what he's done because Aaron Rodgers is
a goat and all you got to do is just
roll the footballs out for him and yet
you know Aaron Rodgers is supposedly not
elite anymore because of the way that
he's playing and then the two things
can't be squared in the same circle and
yet they they have 13 wins Peter you
know it's the whole thing is so strange
rich when you think about it because if
you look at his numbers last year when
supposedly he hit rock-bottom under Mike
McCarthy versus this year you know
significantly more yards per game thrown
for a better Radio all that all that
says it's just it's so weird and it just
goes to show you that Aaron Rodgers is a
fantastic centerpiece but when he has a
running game the crisis the type that he
had this year and when he had the Smith
Brothers the dairy is interested to
really solidify your defense then Aaron
Rodgers doesn't have to win all these
games by himself and Aaron Jones is the
reason why - and he gets snubbed for the
Pro Bowl and he is just dynamic he is
excellent and and I've had him on the
show a couple times just a good kid
yeah good things are properly happening
and again we're not we're not talking
about them Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show and just to Braga's put a
button on all of this that the San
Francisco when aided in fact by a non
pass interference call that is not
reviewed even though the review process
is open exactly to review stuff like
that the team that has to now play one
home game and then potentially go on the
road twice at Green Bay at San Francisco
to get to the Super Bowl is the Saints
it's really amazing how the Saints kind
of why short end of a stick they didn't
get the same break team in the NFC right
now from from what I've seen the last
three or four weeks and and looking to
agrees you know there was a while right
when he came back from his some injury
that everybody said well now we're
seeing the decline of Drew Brees he was
a good quarterback but he wasn't a great
one and and in the last six or seven
weeks he's as good as ever and you know
rich you started off talking about
Philip Rivers and that is an incredible
story in and of itself that could fill
for Rich Eisen shows just in and of
itself and you'll probably spend ten
minutes on it today but just imagine all
of the tentacles to Philip Rivers
what happens if Dean Spanos and Tom
telesco think well geez we really need a
billboard player you know we need a
superstar player to help us sell all
these boxes and luxury seating and PSL
and all that so hey drew Brees and Tom
Brady are both free agents you you know
in March so why don't we go after them
that's why there are so many things to
talk about today that have nothing to do
with coaching and yet just before we get
on the phone I was looking at Twitter
and that's all anybody's talking about
nobody's talking about the fate of the
team so just it's an interesting time in
the NFL especially since Cam Newton
could be free to at some point and what
that means for so many other teams Peter
King here on the Rich Eisen show you
mentioned Brees and before we do get to
the coaching carousel you were part of
the NFL 100 all-time Team Blue
panel and the quarterback reveal show
that just finished up the NFL 100
all-time team show six part series on
Friday night
I knew six months ago that Drew Brees
didn't make it and that would be a big
stink once this was revealed and this
was before he became the all-time leader
in passing touchdowns in passing yards
did you vote for him I mean walk me
through again I don't put you on
sponsors here also a Hall of Fame
selector you this is just a par for your
course and being asked here's the issue
that I that I saw and rich look I
I have per men disrespect for pro
football history and in my opinion what
this came down to is the fact that
basically we were voting on a 98 year
team in many ways because we voted in
June 2018 the problem was voting in June
2018 as the two most efficient accurate
seasons in drew breezers life
did not count and I I'm not saying I'm
convinced but I think it's pretty likely
that if the vote were held right now
that Drew Brees would have made it
likely I would think it's been a Roger
Staubach nothing against Roger Staubach
but I think you know I think you have to
recognize that the time that we voted
was that that you can't put eight
quarterback from the modern era you know
on this and so therefore I believe that
if the vote were today there would be at
least one change and that's AB reason
and I'm not positive who would have been
out maybe unfortunately it would have
been Otto gray or Sammy ball or Sammy
Baugh I don't know
but but all I know is that any team
without Otto Graham and Sammy bar in it
I would I'd be apoplectic right now it
just it would be totally ridiculous
we're not voting you know all these
people I got so many emails to my column
saying it's incredible
didn't vote for this guy that guy or the
other guy who you know who are all these
guys from the 20s and 30s and 40s and
all that and and I just said look you
can't not have a guy who played ten
years at quarterback of professional
football and he made the a major
championship game every year anyone
seven of them
you can't you can't do that so I there
were going to be people who fell by the
wayside and unfortunately in this
particular case I think timing really
cause breathe Peter King here on the
Rich Eisen show in a few minutes I have
with you left let's talk coaching
carousel why did Freddy kitchens get one
and done in Cleveland Peter I mean he
just couldn't get ahold of his team you
that you have Baker Mayfield falling off
a cliff you have internal people say he
was not organized he didn't know uh you
know he didn't know really how to plan
how to coach his team it was never hard
enough on Odell Beckham should have told
Odell Beckham a long time ago look do
you want to be a great player stop being
in Paris or wherever you are in in April
May and June you got to come to these
practices I mean he just he wasn't big
enough for the chair unfortunately and I
really like him
I think he was terrific last year before
Egypt bring that too to the chair this
time so with the expected departure of
Jason Garrett is there any other
surprises that might come do you think
coaching I the only the only I mean the
other two that you know cuz Alliance
changed their mind after Matt Patricia
loses last nine goes 625 and one since
mid season last year Matt Patricia's the
luckiest man out of everyone this
morning because you know look he's
supposed to build a defense that defense
in the last 26 games has allowed 24
points a game and you know you get your
quarterback hurt Wow
everybody gets their quarterback hurt
and and so so again he
lucky and I think he's saying the owner
says he's saying and and we got to take
their word for it the other one I think
is Anthony Lin I think it would be a
major injustice and I don't think he's
gonna get fired but I got an eyebrow
raised over that one they didn't win the
close games this year obviously but you
know he was so good in his first two
years that team was so good I think so
much of this this year was about the
decline of Philip Rivers and can they
fix him will they want to have him back
you know that is stuff as Rivers said
yesterday to decide in the next three
months and how real is Urban Meyer
coming to the pros this year do you
think Peter I mean I I don't know rich I
I don't know and I I would be if I were
a team and it isn't that I don't think
Urban Meyer's a great coach and if his
heart was absolutely into it I'd say
great but I mean he doesn't stay places
long it's like it reminds me a little
bit of Nick Saban and in Miami the
second year I'm not all in I mean the
problem with Urban Meyer is that he's
used to winning nine out of every ten
games if he goes to Cleveland right now
how will he feel about winning six out
of ten or five out of ten and maybe
he'll totally think he could totally
turn it around but I would be very very
I enter that one with three eyes open
because I don't want a guy after two or
three years is going to say I couldn't
make the impact I wanted I'm out hmm
so who is the Dallas favorite then I I
think they're gonna go for a real shiny
object I wrote today that I think hiring
Jason witness would be an extremely dumb
thing and I love Jason Witten everybody
does but how do you put in that in that
absolute circus how do you put a guy
who's used to the circus but has never
run a staff meeting in his life I just
think it's that would be a huge error
and I don't even know if there's legs to
that story or if it's something that's
just a little bit silly
I I guess the other one that I would say
is I if I were Jerry Jones I would
interview Mike McCarthy for eight hours
this week I I mean look I two weeks ago
I spent I don't know a day day and a
half with Mike McCarthy in Green Bay and
rich here's the guy who realizes this a
guy was going to have like a 14 person
analytics slash video department he he
knows that the world is changing in the
NFL and he wants to change along with it
not not entirely but he understands that
he's got to do some things different and
he will and I'm not saying hire him I'm
saying talk to him because I mean at one
point five six seven years ago I mean he
was right there with you know with Sean
Payton and and a lot of these guys who
everybody looked at the as the top head
coaches in the league so I I I would
talk to him because I think Jerry needs
somebody who's going to come in and say
here's how we should do things instead
of just conforming to what Jerry wants
to this Peter loved the time always I
could literally talk to you for the full
hour but I've got to do your podcast
later and I look forward to chatting
with you for the Peter King podcast
later on today Eddie great rich thanks
so much for having known oh you bet
that's Peter King NBC Sports Pro
Football Hall of Famer in his own right
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV for
free on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app